a show of unity and strength
indonesia and the us have held annual
military exercises for more than a
decade
but this year is different as the
exercises expand to include other
countries in asia pacific
really is just a thirst i think in the
region for people to come together for
armies and
militaries to come together to uh to do
this kind of combined training
and
when we're together like this we're
stronger when we're together working
where
we become better joint partners
troops will participate in live fire
exercises medical training search and
rescue operations amphibious exercises
and more in its 16th iteration the
garuda shield exercises have expanded
with its largest ever roster of
participants and a number of countries
participating for the first time japan
is among those countries including in
paratrooper training here in south
sumatra
australia and singapore are also taking
part
and other countries including france
south korea and india are invited to
observe the two-week drills
the exercises are happening at a time of
growing concerns among the us and its
allies about china's military
assertiveness on issues such as taiwan
and the south china sea
washington is trying to project
confidence in the existing international
order and take steps to help ensure it
because the u.s neglected china's
unilateral behavior for a very long time
and now they are making more of an
effort to be able to respond militarily
to china in that regard
indonesia is not a u.s ally and has long
pursued a foreign policy which it
describes as free and active but it has
also pushed back against china's
maritime incursions into its waters
journalists here asked the indonesian
armed forces commander andika perkasa
whether the exercises were intended to
send a message to beijing
not at all we have always done this
training if someone wants to read it
that way well that's not our intention
at all
these drills involving several countries
will continue until mid-august
jessica washington al jazeera baturaja
indonesia